the
hospital software guy
here's what he said uh you'll like this
his was simpler he's like he said yeah
like agree with all that stuff uh here's
how we thought about it
um
we need to have 500 sales people that
can sell
a million dollars worth of product a
year
um or 250 oh oh sorry 500 that could
sell half a million a year or 250 that
could sell a million dollar as their
sales quota per year
so we just work backwards from that all
right
what features products and like people
do we need to like let a salesperson
like get 500 sales people that can sell
half a million dollars a year of like
sales credit like first is that even
possible can the can this market support
that yes the market is very big
hospitals spend a lot of money in health
care and in our category they spend more
than much more than that
[Music]
all right we're live so look um
i
you said sean that you didn't want to
like do an event because you didn't want
to travel i decided to host one anyway
it's just like a meetup
but
do you see the you saw the link that i
posted like the eventbrite thing it's no
big deal but you see it
yeah you posted like an event in new
york with you uh and a bunch of other
like kind of tech buddy friends no just
saw him just me and sahil i was just
like i wanted to just shoot out it i was
like i want to get out of the house i
want to do something you said no
and dude a thousand people have rsvp'd
and i have no idea where we're gonna
host it i have no idea what we're gonna
do i don't have a plan i know nothing
i don't know it sounded like you had a
plan you were like we're moving it to
this other place and it sounded like
something's in the world some guy dm'd
me on twitter and said i'll help you
find a vid a venue and i said great
you're in charge i don't know his name
but
cool you're it
don't take facts
hope it works and then i got nick gray
the uh the small party guy to come and i
was like dude just come and organize
this and you could sell books there
but uh i don't know what i'm gonna do
would it be lame for just stand around
and just say hi
yeah kind of lame
well what the [__] what am i supposed to
do
juggle i don't know should have thought
of that before you posted it bro
like we did the live pod thing uh
in austin miami
and honestly i don't think it was very
good i don't think listening to a
podcast live is that entertaining and
they'll and unless it's like a planned
like comedy skit unless like we like
planned like we had a bit you know what
i mean
like
stage play yeah well no just like that's
what comedians do right you know it's
like scripted but they also kind of flow
a little bit but yeah
or you're just so big that people like
simply the idea of seeing you live is
that entertaining like i don't think
we're there yet like i went to tim
ferriss did a live thing once it was
just him sitting on a chair fireside
chat uh i've seen the guys who do um
whatever that political thing is like
john favreau or whatever they have like
a political podcast pod pod saves
america or something like that they do
live shows and people just like geek out
about meeting them and seeing them
i don't think we're there yet um
and also just in general i'm a big
energy guy and
basically my idea of a good time is
where the energy is like steady up and
rising to the right
and like you know my idea of any kind of
bad time is a dip in energy like the
same way people feel about awkward
silences in a conversation i feel about
energy dips like if i sense the energy
what is that
or hang out because that's what happens
when you do hey we're two dudes from
twitter or a podcast
let's talk in front of you or let's say
hi like
it's just kind of lame isn't it
well
maybe to say say hi that's not helpful
though i i don't know what to do i gotta
i have these people coming i here's what
i think is gonna happen i think that
they're not actually coming to see me
i'm just the excuse for all these
twitter dorks to see one another
so i got an idea that i think would be
dope that you could use for this um
or we could use for something else but
uh basically i was like okay um
like i'll tell you i went to this event
in la just now uh that my buddy romine
threw
and it's like whatever there's a
conference but the day before the
conference there's like the dinner and
now this was like a ball or dinner it
was like at uh the home of an nba team
owners like on his rooftop looking at
the beach it was like beautiful right
but like even if it wasn't that baller
of a of a surroundings like the house
wasn't that sick this still would have
been awesome because it's basically the
table was full of like basically there
was two tables each table had like one
really famous person
and then like two kind of famous people
and then the rest were interesting but
not famous people
and just simply like there was a copy
which one
which one of those were you
i was the just interesting person
got it okay i just try to understand
like the level of fame we're talking
about no no i'm talking about like real
fame like professional athlete actor
that's that level of fame which actors
were there
i can't say the names of anybody that
was there it was actually it was a it
was an athlete event not not so much
actors but like a list of people
uh of
the athletes it was like former a-list
it's like a former b-list let's say it's
like uh i you know
i you're not on the cover of the video
game but like you know i remember your
name i've seen you play i had written
university cards you know that gamer's
attributes yeah yeah exactly i can tell
you exactly i have memories of you
playing the game not like a bench warmer
so anyways but the my point is these
dinner tape like basically just like a
table and whether that table is like
you're playing poker or you're eating
food or something like that just like a
round table of like eight people where
the expectation is that hey we're all
here to get to know each other like
we're all here to talk and then you kind
of can rotate i think we could do one of
those for the mfm community where we
take the like 10 or 15 like most baller
guests so it's like andrew wilkinson has
his table and you have your table i have
my table and then steph smith has her
table and ben has his table and like we
just do this with like kind of like
well-known business people we take you
know we get whoever you know our famous
guests a rob deer deck or we get biology
or whatever we get some of these people
to show up
and then we curate the rest of the guest
list is you are interesting but you're
not necessarily famous so maybe you got
a really interesting business maybe
you're really like knowledgeable about
some science or domain or something like
that you're just like a nerd in your own
right
um but they're all fans and we basically
just set up these tables and it's like
whatever this room of ten tables and
whether it's food or poker or something
there's some activity to do while you're
there just casually while you're talking
and uh and you get to hop so you get to
rotate between i don't know three or
four of these tables while you're there
random draws and uh and like that's the
event i think people have more fun with
some something like that because they
participate than sitting in them and
watching other people talk that's my my
personal guess so i would do that for an
mfm event bro
great that's cool but i have a thousand
people coming on
can we have 10 people in a hundred
person tables
that's a lot that's a lot of a lot
you don't have to let all thousands that
was a interest list that wasn't uh
you're you're accepted in right
i don't know i do i made this was a
toilet event i made it on my phone i was
on toilet and i tweeted it out and
it worked here's what i think you should
do i think you should uh whatever you do
something the sam way you're like all
right everybody we're all meeting in
this junkyard we're gonna look for cool
scraps and like that'll filter out
people you wanna hang out with it'll be
a no headache event and then separately
i will host this cool event that's well
planned
and you just have to show up to that you
don't have to do any work
um whatever
we'll see uh
can i talk to you about one thing really
quick and then i wanna hear about your
event dude have you listened to the full
send podcast
uh like not regularly but i've
definitely seen clips like when they had
dana white or mark cuban i see a bunch
of clips i don't exactly understand what
full send is but i know they're
incredibly popular like it's i don't
know if it's like a boy band where it's
like four
guys doing something or if it's just the
two main guys and the rest are co-hosts
but it's basically a group of like
yeah go ahead can i explain what it is
roughly
so i'm also not an expert but it's
basically the group is the milk boys
that's like the main name of the group
full send is like their brand and one of
their podcasts and stuff like that but
these guys are basically the way i think
about it is they are like what jackass
was when we were growing up that's what
the elk boys are now so the so jackass
back in the day was basically guys doing
you know stunts pranks you know punching
each other's balls basically a group of
guys who are kind of like they're
willing to go all out for your
entertainment and their own amusement
they kind of um
they they live a certain lifestyle and
it's kind of like the like
if you take a boys like fantasy you just
like crank it up to 12 it's like that's
what these guys do the elk boys are a
little bit like that they make youtube
videos they got big on youtube
they also have a bunch of brands so they
have one brand that's basically an
equivalent of girls gone wild it's like
a paid membership club that's like
for photos or videos of something i
don't know
i didn't know about that
that's called i don't know ben find the
name of that one um so that's one of
their businesses that i think is really
smart probably prints money they have
merch that they drop and they've done
merge drops uh they like show the live
stream and they're like doing it
obviously there's a little bit of hype
but like whatever they're basically like
the shopify dropshipper bro on steroids
they'll do like two or three million
dollars worth of sales in like five
minutes when they do a drop so the new
york times
well new york times said last year they
did about 80 million in revenue which is
pretty good but right 50 million in
merchandise it says i think
yeah and then it said they're on track
to do eight or maybe 70 the next year
and this article is a year old and then
uh they have this new shtick going on
and ft they got all types of crap but
then if you go to that link that i sent
you each guy has like a video page
and one of these guys his name is steve
and i think this is like a point where i
realized i'm out of touch he's just like
giving away a million dollars in every
video
[Laughter]
literally like mr beast playbook but
he's like giving too much he's like here
i just gave this guy a hundred thousand
dollar watch i just gave this family two
million dollars and in all these videos
he goes yeah i'm gonna go uh give this
guy a car and then he was with dana and
he goes i'm gonna uh dana i just got
this 400 000 van made it's yours
um
on one of the videos they gave a guy 250
000 in cash for his birthday on another
thing they're giving away 200 000 just
to her family in need like so whatever
find videos but he's doing these
multiple times a month these guys are
going to run out of money
right
i have no idea how they give this much
away or if they have so much give it
away it's so it's actually just like you
know
you know like a stage thing or if
there's some like caveats or whatever i
have they they should do an apartment
they show the guy's apartment and he's
got uh his watch collection and i know a
little bit of watches it's literally
three million dollars worth of rolexes
and then it's like well four million i
believe that they could have dope stuff
but literally giving away a million
dollars kind of crazy and if i look at
his youtube channel he does do that
sometimes but like he has other ones
like here's my three million dollar man
cave here's you know uh here's me you
know whatever buying this car or racing
this car so that's a little different
than giving it away but um i know like
so did you watch when mr beast was doing
this when he would go and he would
basically give away thirty thousand
fifty thousand dollars or he'd go into a
twitch stream that has like two viewers
he would just drop 20 grand in a
donation and the person would freak out
and that that clip would go viral like
yeah did you see those and do you know
how he was doing those
i i know uh i know they exist and i saw
them i don't know like the anything but
behind behind
one of the things that he was doing i
don't know if this is the full story ben
maybe you know
you're friends with mr b so maybe you
know you know
he seems to consider you one of his top
three closest friends uh
that's a plan um
you may know better but i remember
meeting one guy who worked at this site
called
quid quib something like that quid i
think it was and basically quid was like
these like i don't know little
collectible stickers and cards or
something like that
um it was kind of like aimed at a
teenage audience and what they did was
they would go to mr beast and they would
say hey we'll pay you 50 000 for sponsor
video and the genius of mr beast was he
was like cool but here's what we're
gonna do
that's not you paying me for a shout out
midway through one of my videos let's
make the video about using fifty
thousand dollars an interesting way how
about that
and so he would do these videos where he
would be like i'm gonna go to this
coffee shop and i'm gonna tip the
barista fifteen thousand dollars and
let's see her reaction and he would go
and he would tip her she would have this
crazy reaction he'd be like thanks so
much to our guys at cr quiv who made
this possible um you know go check them
out they do this thing right that video
would get like five million or ten
million views and so for the for quid or
whatever they were like dude this is
great like we're getting way more bang
for our buck than any other influence or
shout out we're doing so then they would
up the ante they would do fifty thousand
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
because each video was getting like ten
million views and it was this like
perfectly
like i forgot what it's called in
biology where like the parasite actually
helps you like sucks out the toxins so
the parasites getting food but you're
also getting healed it was basically
like a symbiotic relationship like that
where
the
the brand was basically putting up loads
of cash and he was using that to create
huge amounts of views and subscribers to
make himself the biggest i don't think
these guys have that's cool i don't
think these guys have sponsors
well they must have it somewhere right
like the model must be that
either it's the same thing the money
comes in one one door then they reinvest
it in stuff like this because they know
that seems to be a pretty good formula i
give away you know i'm gonna give this
family in the hood a hundred thousand
dollars uh you know let's see what
happens and it's him standing with like
three you know three bucks in front of
home depot that's literally the the
second most recent video and it's got
2.7 million views so clearly that works
this video will monetize um no on top of
that that's that's their whole shtick is
they got banned they can't monetize
their videos
oh okay yeah i don't know how it's
sustainable maybe it's not sustainable
but by the way and it's also explicit i
don't think you could put ads on an
explicit channel but just like the
economics behind what these guys are
doing
it's
it's it's outrageous to me something is
crazy i i i don't think i'm though i i
think when i see this and i predict that
they're going to go broke i don't think
i'm the crazy one
yeah baby
i could see that i could also see these
things being money printers so like in
the same way that i think the jackass
franchise ultimately was successful
right you see like
oh dude there's like a [__] in a thong
you know kicking this other guy in the
balls you're like well this doesn't seem
like good business but in actuality as
long as they have a good man as long as
they have their kris jenner in the
background that's like yeah go act the
full like this is this is what drives
ratings then this will work and like the
new york times headline about them
is
what won't the nelq boys do and this is
like how like that's a brand right
that's a really powerful valuable brand
to own is
the question isn't what do they do it's
what they what won't they do it's like
they do pranks parties crude humor they
get in trouble but the backlash is the
brand that's literally the the headline
now would they go i don't know i don't
know enough about them but you know i'm
actually a fan of what they do i think
they're pretty cool we should get them
on the pod i want to hear hear their
business i agree i think one of their
manager asked to come on maybe we can
talk to them i heard um a story about a
friend a person i know who made 60
million dollars a handful of years ago
living in living out of their car now
i learned that this weekend
so i know a person who made 60 million
dollars like 10 years ago
and now they are homeless
yeah
dude that's crazy
that's not even crazy that's normal bro
like uh jack dorsey is like you know
starts two multi-billion dollar
companies and then like actively tries
to dress like you know a homeless guy
like you know
this that's the thing you do when you
get rich you then go on some journey to
like find the meaning of life in fact i
was telling somebody this the other day
we were reminiscing it's like dude at
the event i was like dude i haven't seen
you in so many years like oh when was
the last time i saw you it was like
remember we were advising that kid on
his company
and we were both afterwards like yeah
but that's never going to work like you
know
you know a good kid but like you know
he'll be maybe he'll be successful in
like five years
and then his company currently is like a
multi-billion dollar company and i was
like now that motherfucker's 25 years
old running around like with a huge
beard trying to like figure out like
basically trying to figure out the
meaning of life like oh [__] you're on a
spiritual journey already damn it you're
like you are so far ahead of us now
after we kind of were joking around
about how you you know you you don't
have this thing figured out that is the
like the classic tech cliche is to like
be like get i made all this money so
that i'm gonna live like somebody who
has no money that's like the stereotype
i want to get to your event but really
quick one more thing because this is
the new cliche
so i hate talking about these guys but
elon um
in the wall street journal came out
yesterday that elon musk slept with
sergey brin the guy started google his
wife right and sergey aren't friends at
all elon tweeted two things that were
hilarious the one he goes this isn't
true i haven't had sex in forever
i haven't had sex with months yeah
and then the next thing that he tweeted
was here's
me and sergey hanging out right now on a
boat and it's them like drinking wine
together like partying did he post a
picture yes
or yeah either he did or someone did it
he
replied to it said yeah that was us
literally yesterday
that's so funny yeah it's so funny
here's what i here's how i was feeling
about this i was like all right
i saw the saw the news break or whatever
it was like scoop on the wall street
journal scoop exclusive scoop
elon musk sleeping with whatever blah
blah blah and uh and i was like okay
that's kind of interesting i guess like
all right i got some tmz [__]
and um i was like well pretty sad for
like you know the wall street it was the
wall street journal uh i feel pretty sad
that that's like the wall street journal
thing but of course i get it if i had
that story i'd publish it too no doubt
then he tweets out like the like the
thing like not true
and haven't had sex in months psy and i
was like ah now another sad thing like
first wall street journal disappointed
me then elon musk disappointed me like
dude i want my billionaires like being
cool not like dude that was like my msn
like away message you know just a cry
for attention back in middle school or
high school i was like oh man
it wouldn't be nice to get like i wonder
what a kiss feels like you know some
[__] like that that's like dude
lame and then and i was like well
so did the wall journal just make that
up because that's even lamer so it was
just like a lame sandwich that i was not
into uh but i just thought it was
hilarious how he he tweeted a picture of
him and sergey just hanging out
uh i enjoyed this drama i'm here for it
i don't care about the cars i don't care
about the solar stuff i just like this
type of crap
yeah somebody had this great tweet they
were like uh
elon musk is like you know
he's on some pirate [__] he's taking
over companies like twitter he's trying
to like conquer new lands like mars he's
sleeping with his friend's girlfriends
like he's he's on he's on that pirate
[__] and i was like oh yeah it's true
that's cool if true but it sounds like
you know maybe this one's not actually
true
all right what's this what's this event
uh by the way we forgot to say on the
milk boys they have like their beer
which i think is also like a big thing
their happy dad like seltzer or beer or
whatever the heck that is
um
happy dad is like everywhere on
instagram like it's like the main brand
i've seen a lot of people drink it
yeah i've seen it
so i wanna tell you some things about
this event and these are to be kind of
rapid fire little nuggets
you can choose to say the following you
can either say
that's stupid and i'll simply move on i
won't defend it you'll say that's cool i
have nothing to add and i'll simply move
on or we could talk about any of these
things all right so i go to this event
in l.a
uh my buddy romine who uh we run our
fund together he
hosts this event
um
and it's basically like athletes and big
shot investors so at this event we're
like
three or four owners of like sports
teams so these are basically like
billionaires or billionaire families
like legacy families how did you get
these people
they just wanted to come i guess i don't
know he just called reach out that he's
not paying anybody and it's a free event
so there's nothing there's like no money
to be made but this is just like in
network
then there's pro athletes mostly retired
athletes but some active players like
kind of like some guys from the lakers
some guys from other other teams that
are younger guys but then some older
guys that are retired and they're like
on to the next phase of their their
business life and they maybe are doing
content now they got like a media brand
or they're doing real estate or whatever
and so the idea was let's get together
like 50
people from the world of sports and 50
people from the world of like tech and
business and let's see what happens so i
went last year i went this year again
and i have a couple of like little
stories so the first is um
i'm going to tell you there was one talk
that was good there was it was like a
bunch of talks on the day of the
conference
um
there was only one talk that i thought
was good and by the way that's [__]
on myself too i i was i hosted a panel
too i didn't think was very good um but
the one was really good was basic
lessons from billion dollar founders so
onstage was the ceo of carta so uh
carter they do cap table management
they're a multi-billion dollar company
um something called um
oh shoot what was it it's like a therapy
app the name will come to me it's
basically like mental health
it's like a better hope but it's not
them it's like some other competitive
space
uh another one but basically they
basically do like therapy and mental
health um
through telemedicine like online and uh
and there's another one that was like
some hospital software a theolos and
then there was uh this most interesting
one is something called relativity space
and by the way
you could basically tell you know
i wouldn't say that the most interesting
person at a conference is always the one
who dresses differently
but somebody who's dressed very
differently is almost always very
interesting at these conferences
last year when i was there i told you i
saw this kid who looked like a break
dancer wearing this like tie-dye shirt
with like a black stud earring it looked
different than every other you know suit
in the room and it was the founder of
bolt who now has become a lot more
famous because he like you know went on
these twitter tirades and bolt is a
multi-billion dollar company and all
this stuff but i met him there and
invested in his company because i was
like this dude's just really interesting
so that happened again this guy is the
founder of relativity space he's
competing with elon his two competitors
are jeff bezos and elon musk uh like you
know no big deal i'm competing with the
world's richest man and like second rich
man basically tim ellis tim ellis yeah
and so i'm just going to share with you
two things one is this dude's company is
insane so relativity space what they do
is they 3d print rockets
and then they send them into space so
basically there's a huge huge demand for
rocketry so the ability to take
satellites up to space to do you know
some scientific missions whatever and
right now spacex is like the number one
blue origin which is jeff bezos company
is number two and relativity space is
number three uh but they kind of have a
differentiator which is all those other
companies like to build a rocket they
need like whatever hundreds of parts
like specialty parts and they might 3d
print individual parts but like the
whole thing is like a very expensive
complex structure that where a million
things can go wrong whereas these guys
basically 3d print the entire rocket
with only a couple extra parts and uh
and so because of that they're like you
know cheaper and whatever he said this
line this throwaway line he's like so
he's explaining he's like you know our
mission is to make humanity like
humanity multiplanetary uh through 3d
printing rockets we're one of only two
companies on earth that has a mission of
making the human race like multi
multiplanetary the other is spacex he
goes the launch part market today is
eight billion a year so eight billion
gets spent launching things into space
and is growing to 30 billion uh there's
really only three companies that
possibly can serve this right now
um and he's like you know um we in the
last three months we have we've sold
over 1.2 billion in uh launch
and launch sales
i was like what
and he started he started the company he
was 25 he's 32 now so he used to work at
jeff bezos company blue as an intern his
wikipedia says as an intern and he was
trying to do 3d printing there he was
like hey i think this is like one of the
ways we can dramatically reduce the cost
and complexity of rockets and it was
like yeah nice r d but like it wasn't
the main way they were doing things so
he left and he starts this thing he goes
we have 850 employees 500 are x spacex
and i thought that was literally the
funniest [__] anybody could say i was
like
what kind of absurd statement is that
that's so amazing to me
um
and he's like you know we have a launch
site now that was like the big progress
last year we have a launch site so we're
going to be doing our first big like uh
like our i don't know if our first big
our next big launch there uh there are
only four launch sites in the country
none have been built since 1960 and we
now have exclusive rights to one for the
next 25 years it's like you know he's
basically because in this talk he's like
what makes a company worth so much
because people will see me okay i'm a
young guy i'm a young guy company's not
that old and it's worth how many
billions of dollars like that's crazy
and he's like well
here's what we did he's like
we hopped into an emerging wave so we
basically like there's surging demand
for um for going in for missions in
space for satellites and more
um there's not enough supply there's
basically like not much competition
everybody's sort of scared away so in
actuality like just going into the space
we're not competing with most companies
um the next one is
you know we
um basically we're like defensibility we
have a launch site there's only four of
these none have been built in like you
know 60 years
and um and we have we have one of them
and so like you know what we're going to
do
what's this have to do with the
billionaire
lessons
well these are lessons what does it take
to build a billion dollar company these
are the core elements like defensibility
that's you know that's one of their
moats the next one is like this like
this co extreme imbalance and supply and
demand
dude how lame must you feel if you're
like a software guy like carter like
following this guy
you know what i mean they each had to
say their thing so i'll tell you what
each of them said so this is what this
guy was saying all right the next guy
the the telehealth guy or that's not
telehealth sorry the uh hospital
software guy
here's what he said uh you'll like this
his was simpler he's like he said yeah
like agree with all that stuff uh here's
how we thought about it
um
we need to have 500 sales people that
can sell
a million dollars worth of product a
year
um or 250 oh oh sorry 500 that could
sell half a million a year or 250 that
can sell a million dollar as their sales
quota per year
so we just work backwards from that all
right
what features products and like people
do we need to like let a salesperson
like get 500 sales people that can sell
half a million dollars a year of like
sales credit like first is that even
possible can the can this market support
that yes the market is very big
hospitals spend a lot of money in health
care and in our category they spend more
than much more than that
okay cool so it's possible then
he's like all of our product team they
know they work for sales and i thought
that was very different than what most
people say he's like
silicon valley loves to preach that like
product is king product is the god you
just need a great product he was like we
build great product if it's gonna help
us sell better and like we build great
customer support so that it helps us
sell better everything is in service of
sales so i really like that guy's kind
of like one-liner approach the carter
guy basically was like
um you know we uh he's like here's how i
think about it he's like you need uh you
need to you basically you want to find a
multi-billion dollar wave if you're
gonna be a billion dollar company he's
like so find an emerging wave so for
example that the telehealth guy his is
that his was that uh mental health
coverage was now required so like a
bunch of i don't know if it's like
insurance companies or companies they
were now requiring that like uh mental
health is part of a health care package
he's like that changed you know second
thing that changed was mental health is
getting de-stigmatized you're seeing all
kinds of famous people talking about
mental health it's not like this taboo
subject like i call it years ago it's
only inflections so there's like
regulatory inflections which is like all
right now you could do telemedicine
that's a new thing there's uh cultural
inflections which is wow it's not weird
to talk in front of your camera anymore
and like make a video there's
technology technology technological
inflections which is like oh wow our
phones all have gps's so you want to
like look for different inflections
right
exact that's exactly what he was saying
and the last one he mentioned was like
the pandemic was another inflection
because it forced everybody if they
needed a doctor visit to do a
video on so it's like a everybody had to
try it for this two year period
and so video visits and telemedicine not
now the hospitals know they need to have
it uh doctors know they need to be
willing to do this and patients have
like tried it once
uh all right the next thing he goes he
goes team he goes billion dollar
companies are almost never bootstrapped
so you kind of have to know that going
in like if you're gonna build a billion
dollar company you almost certainly are
gonna raise money because you're gonna
hire a plus players they need to have an
a plus mission and secondly you need to
have a high velocity customer
acquisition model
and i just thought that phrase is very
good high velocity customer acquisition
model it's something you can just kind
of ask yourself do i or don't i have a
high velocity customer acquisition model
every business wants one pretty much
and you got to say like okay what's our
current velocity so at what rate are we
currently adding customers
how high would it need to be for us to
get there and like what are we going to
do to make this this little wheel spin
faster
um all right but let me just thought
that was good those four guys there's
four people right four guys
yeah yeah did were they a
tired and exhausted looking
and b do you think they are happy
all right we'll give you the scale the
mental health guy honestly looked not
tired and happy
um he was like fit he didn't have like
crazy bags under his eyes he like spoke
with energy and he was like sitting
upright that makes sense dad checks out
carter guy
he looked calm like he didn't look like
he was facing death but he looked like
he like
had been facing death for some extended
period yeah
he only has five hunched over
yeah like you know i could tell he
wasn't in bad shape at all but uh you
know like it didn't look like you know
he was springing around with energy
necessarily right uh space guy that guy
looked like he just walked in it looked
like he just walked out of a room you
know like those scenes in game of
thrones were like oh shoot we're going
to war and the guy like gets up and out
of his bed scramble like four
nude women and he's like ah okay yeah
let me just go do my next thing that's
how this guy looked he had the swagger
of a guy in game of thrones who was just
sleeping with four women four beautiful
women he had the tyrion lannister energy
um he and that's when he was like yeah
billion dollars in sales in the last
three months and like you know we have
500 ex spacex employees yeah they leave
elon to come so he seemed like he was
like that's the energy he was carrying
he looked happy damn well [__] you guys
[Laughter]
i i was sitting with him at lunch and he
was asking questions to everybody else
and like that was one of the most that
was one of the coolest parts of this
event i don't know how they did it but
nobody had an ego like everybody who was
there i don't know if they just filtered
people out who had egos or they just
like everybody got the vibe which is
like everybody here is equally valuable
be curious about others you're not just
like the star and all these people are
used to being the star it's like yeah
you're you own that in that nba team you
own that football team or like you're
like this superstar like you know the
guy on my panel with me i think he had
like you know 90 million dollars he had
a 90 he just signed like a 90 million
contract he's like one of the highest
paid nfl players and uh the guy was like
dude i'm just here to learn man i would
love to you know subscribe to your
newsletter and blah blah blah i'm like
wow this is incredible you are going to
go so far in life because
you are obviously skilled and successful
but you're so humble it's crazy damn how
many people were there
about 100 120 maybe romaine organized
this
yeah so basically romaine and then tribe
which is like a vc fund um
uh tribe was one of the hosts and then
tpg which is like one of the biggest
private equity companies in the world
like why is this this guy working with
you 120 billion
what why is this guy working with you
bro i always have that tyrion dinosaur
energy regardless of what my situation
is
holy crap this guy's amazing well that's
badass i was in l.a
i was in l.a i'm gonna give you a couple
other things that i i took away from
this
ben so ben levy who's not producer ben
my business partner ben
he has a super power that we talk about
now have i told you about his superpower
his superpower to me is
um people just tell him [__] and he just
smiles and laughs and then he uses it
against them
if if he needs to [__] trust magnet
yeah i don't know what he does everybody
trusts him like me and you i've known
you for i don't know how long i've been
like eight years we've spent time
together we've gone through ups and
downs
adversity we've seen each other whatever
we know each other very well you may
have met ben twice in your life
but even you will be like if if there's
something interesting or something going
on you like text ben like dude my new
business is doing awesome or something
like that and he just has that pull with
people everybody wants to talk to ben
everyone's to tell him he's so
enthusiastic
i don't know what it is but i saw a
super home blast so i'm gonna tell you a
little story here and i don't even know
how much we can take away from this i'm
just gonna kind of explain that it
happened just so that
just because i think it was amazing and
because i think that
if there is a way to learn this skill
everybody should learn it i'm trying to
learn it myself so i'm going to talk out
loud about it so we go to this event at
the event i get a text from ben ben
sitting across the room we we split up
at the events we don't always just sit
together and just only talk to each
other because that's kind of defeats the
purpose
and he's like yo the dude next to you uh
he's awesome and i go who he goes he
goes that's chris johnson or that's this
guy who he trains like some of the best
nba players on the planet
um and i was like oh really like i'm a
big nba fan i was like i don't know this
guy like he must follow him on instagram
like ben's just like even deeper down
the rabbit hole so i was like okay cool
but i was like i don't know what to do
with that information like i guess like
if the opportunity kind of presents
itself i'll i'll go introduce myself
like you know i have nothing to yeah i
don't know how to force my way any seems
busy right now but okay
ben does something where he i don't know
i don't know what he did but he
approached this guy
ben approached this guy
and he starts talking to him and i i
think two things happen i think number
one
in a room full of the guys who are
usually on screen
um
this guy who himself is obviously like a
heavy hitter in his space
a lot the average joe did not know who
he was right like every tech nerd who
was in there doesn't know who this guy
is even people who like sports probably
didn't know that this guy's like the you
know the skills trainer for all these
top guys and i'm talking about like this
guy will train with dwyane wade and
lebron james and like other guys like
that like the top of the top
and um ben goes up to him he's like dude
i follow you man i love your videos it
gives them a compliment they start
chatting a little bit
i don't know what ben said next but i
think
i'm going to skip to the end and we'll
fill it in the middle the end is
the event's over everybody's leaving
people going to the airport this guy
comes up to me and he sees i'm talking
about we're figuring out we're gonna get
our uber he goes
i knew i was coming to this event for a
reason but i didn't know why
this man was the reason he pointed no
way
and i go
what and i was like what do you mean
like what did he do he's like i don't
even know man he goes this i am so happy
i met this guy ben i will always
remember our conversation he goes he
said something he goes like
he goes he's like he's
he's like bro brother anything you need
anything you need i got you and i was
like and he this is not the type of guy
he's not schmoozing this is not this is
a guy where when words come out of his
mouth they mean something
and i'm just like i'm just sitting there
i'm not even laughing i'm not even
asking questions i'm speechless i get
this look on my face like what the [__]
did you do ben how did you do this again
and and ben still he's just smiling you
don't even say anything back to this guy
he's just smiling and i go i go what i
go what did he i go what happened why
he goes i guess i don't even he goes i
don't even know he doesn't even know the
spell he's under he goes i don't even
know but he goes you know i'm a trainer
man i work with athletes when they need
something they call me when they're in a
slump they call me when they're trying
to get better they come when they want
their next contract they call me i help
these guys get paid i'm always helping i
drive to this guy's house i drive here i
fly there i do this i do that i'm always
pouring into other people he goes ben
you filled me up you poured into me oh
man and i was like
what just happened
i was so amazed
and the guy goes the guy goes when are
you flying out and ben's like tomorrow
he goes
come train with us tomorrow
ben goes with him the next morning to
his facility and does a session the guy
spends two hours correcting ben's form
there's other nba players there he's
locked into bed
ben sends me this video he's wearing
like a [__] weighted vest he's got a
glove on his hand because this guy like
invented a shooting glove
he made an experience out of it for ben
and i i really appreciate this guy
didn't have to do that that was
incredibly nice of this guy he was just
very like i don't know he was very like
you could see why this guy works with so
many people because there's something
magnetic about this guy's personality
what's his name but two magnets met dude
and i don't know how i don't know what
ben's superpower is i don't know how he
does this consistently these sorts of
things happen where people are just very
um attracted to him in this way i don't
know what it is but he's amazing it's
you know who else is really good at that
me
i'm [__] good at that
i'm good at that
you are good at that i'm not that good
but i'm good yeah
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a test from three days ago i
totally
missed hubspot grow better
so yesterday we'll talk about a second
but yesterday i did an interview with
martin shkreli
and um
and i wanted it to go well i was like
yeah okay you know i think people can be
interested in this let me do a good job
and i'm five minutes into the interview
and i find myself doing the like
[__] socialize i'm like hahaha yeah
i'm like smiling i'm laughing i'm like
so that must have been hard for you to
blah blah and what would you say i'm
just like falling into some [__] like
script
like i don't know what i like became
some character this like generic podcast
character and literally the thought of
my head was sam would never do this sam
like he's he he said something he was
like he was talking about like yeah how
he like he's like yeah dude i i got a
contraband cell phone i was on the
internet the whole time i was in prison
and i was like and i was like uh i
started and i was like dude if somebody
oh no you know you know what i would ask
that's great what what websites were you
using like where were you where were you
going
you would have been like wait what how
do you get in there do you like get it
like you have to put it between your
butt cheeks
you would have said something like that
to kind of disarm him to get him to
share an interesting nugget and you
would have just genuinely been like wait
what the hell like hold on no and you
would have just reacted like a normal
person rather than like
that's fascinating you know um i'm
curious to hear your thoughts on blah
blah blah it's like dude that's
podcaster versus real person and so i
was i like literally switched into sam
mode and i started being like i was like
what are you doing and then he shares
this in hilarious things he goes yeah
dude and you you you would have been
like how much was it i was like how much
you get the phone for he's like dude
he's crazy he's like you have to buy
these things for like thousands of
dollars like i paid 15 000 for one phone
and i thought [__] this phone must be
made out of gold because he's like but
you have to do it because to get the
phone in they got a grease you know one
guy to get one guy to get another guy
you gotta bribe five guys to get this in
and so like you know you gotta pay that
vig and he's like most guys i was like
so what do you use it for exactly your
question he goes
he goes yeah most guys just use for porn
he's like he's like but me i'm i'm on
github and like khan academy and porn i
did that too but like you know the only
guys using this for like advanced math
also you know under the covers listening
to this and that little magic moment
that came out yeah it was great it's
like that doesn't happen
that doesn't happen unless
you kind of act the way that you act at
banks where it's like yours is a little
different yours is like you get to like
real talk really fast
ben just kind of like seems so curious
and earnest i think that people really
like they like how genuinely interested
he is in their life and how he how
helpful he tries to be without like
seeking anything or talking about
himself have you read the book how to
win friends that influence people
i read like the first chapter where it
was like the the people's favorite word
in the english their name yeah and i was
like yeah this is great dude that book
that book like changed my life and in
one of the chapters he talks about how
uh there was a story of a man like
sitting with the with a young guy and
the young guy like wanted something like
a job or something from the from the
older guy but the young guy you know
used dale carnegie's practices and
basically like he just listened to him
the entire time and you know the older
guy did all the talking and at the end
of the uh
the end of the conversation the other
guy goes wow this was the best
conversation i've ever had with anyone
ever and the younger guy was like well i
didn't say a word so but like that
that's funny how that works and the
older guy goes like you know you should
we're friends now you should come and
like apply at our company you know like
things like that and that like changed
my life when i learned when i learned
that strategy and so when i want to get
stuff from people
i usually amp them up
so i'll do one of two things one i'll
either insult them a little bit like if
i know that their business is doing
above 100 million in revenue i'm like
that's that's a nice little business
what do you guys do like 50 million like
and and then they're gonna like tell me
the exact so i'll like make them a
little or the thing that i do more often
than not is i just encourage them like
crazy like wow you did that you are so
amazing you're my hero dude how did you
do that you know and they'll like start
like gushing and i'll just make them
feel really good about themselves this
sounds manipulative which i guess it is
but i don't think it's a bad
manipulative but yeah it works
yeah the way i put it is like you go to
these events to make connections with
new people right that's the point or we
wouldn't go to an event if it wasn't for
that
but it's kind of hard to do that i find
myself like feeling uncomfortable in a
lot of those situations you know like
okay i need to introduce myself to this
person how do i quickly you know like
are they interested in me am i them
there's very much like a like a dating
component to that to this like a speed
dating component to these events and you
sort of see their eyes start to wander
it's like oh they're clearly like
looking for the next conversation or
like you know the bathroom or some
excuse to get out of this sort of thing
or
you're like or you find yourself tuning
out because you're like oh shoot i'm
just kind of judging them like really
quickly like everybody's got something
to offer i just wanna i should be in the
mode of like finding out what that is
rather than like
looking at their badge and trying to
figure out like are you you know
valuable at this conference or not
that's sort of a stupid way to do it but
like i am fascinated with ben and this
guy chris their their ability to connect
was so strong like
the way chris talked to me too i felt
like a friend of his within two minutes
and it's not because he was manipulating
me no he's just like that's his energy
he carries around so if i think about
why has he been able to connect with
these athletes who everybody wants to
connect with them everybody wants to
connect with lebron james everybody
wants to connect with kevin durant
everybody wants to connect with dwyane
wade
how does this guy do it well obviously
he's got to be good at his job but
that's not enough you also have to have
the people's skills he told me a story i
think i could share this on here
by the way he wants to come on the pod
i'll tell him to come on but he showed
he told me the story so i don't know if
you pay you probably don't pay attention
to this but did any of the people who
you met listen
oh yeah there were some people who
listened to the pod i just got them
yeah not not a town i would say but like
definitely a few um one of the franchise
owners listens which is kind of really
um
and so or like he had listen i don't
know if he's super regular but um
uh so okay so he was so basically this
guy was talking about the trainer he was
talking about like uh uh fear and so he
so he was like he
somehow we got on the topic of fear he's
like yeah man i was like i work with
these guys in the gym
they can hit like you know whatever 80
90 93 pointers in a row like 80 90
percent but in the game it's obviously
lower and sure it's the speed is there
the defense is a little tighter but like
take free throws there's no defense
there's no speed still the guys in the
gym perform one way and in the game they
form another it's because there's a huge
mental component to this he's like so i
train their mental just as much as
they're physical and he's like you know
um
lebron recently went to
play at this thing called the drew
league i don't know if you've ever seen
this but it's like
it's in downtown l.a it's like in the
hood basically the true league lebron i
don't think has ever played and it's
usually like kind of like former players
or like fringe guys journeyman guys who
want to make a league they're very good
basketball but they're not like stars
and um lebron was like i'm thinking
about going and dropping in and just
playing
and and this trainer was like that would
be awesome and that would like mean a
lot like i think it would mean a lot to
the people i think you would you would
have fun it's a legacy thing like just
it's like one time kevin durant went to
rucker park and he played in rucker park
he dropped like 50 points or something
like that and the crowd like mobbed and
they just like ended the game because
the crowd just rushed him because he was
being so awesome and he just hit a three
from from half court basically like he
just gets mobbed by people it was like
this very memorable thing and so the guy
was like you should do it but like
lebron has a lot to lose at something
like this right lebron's already one of
the best players in the world already
one of the richest most famous athletes
in the world so he doesn't need the fame
he's not going to get any money he's not
going to get better like just by playing
in this one game with people who are
worse than him like um and there's
plenty of things that could go wrong
like he could get hurt he could get
dunked on or embarrassed and way crossed
over in some way like you know that sort
of thing or he could just like miss
shots and like uh man he went and it was
like
dude you couldn't even like you weren't
you ain't all that like you know it
wasn't like hype
so he had something to lose and um but
he decided to go and then the trainer
was she like pulls up his cell phone
it's like the nba all-star game is his
imessage like just one star after
another he's like he clicks the text
message with me he's like he told he's
like i told him your victory is in your
vulnerability
like this you felt you were vulnerable
that's why this was a win for you
because he went it was amazing everybody
loved it he played super well dropped 40
points and like it was awesome uh and
the clips go viral on instagram and
people really respect him for it he goes
you remember that your victory is in
your vulnerability and he looked around
the circle he was just like remember
that and all of us are like nodding like
yes sir
i was like i will i what do i need to be
i will take my clothes off right now and
be more vulnerable if it helps me be
like
you know like but he was really
inspiring telling these stories and so i
love meeting people like this i love
hearing stories like this and i love
getting these golden nuggets these
little things you can take away that
like you can use in your own little your
own life you know what my takeaway when
i hear this [__] is is
damn these guys are cool i want to be
[__] cool like like i want to stick
how the [__] do you have to be cool i
just google at amazon how to be cool
where's this book i need one of these
books i don't want i want men to want me
like
yeah how do you be cool dude where's
that book on how to be cool i want that
this guy read it i want to read it too
that's crazy
to read that book too
yeah
i'm so envious when i hear people like
this i'm like damn they got a good stick
let me tell you one other little nugget
here
do memorable things i wrote this down
all right what does that mean
i went to the conference last year i
went this year in between i've like
launched a business i've you know the
podcast has grown blah blah blah
guess what the number one thing people
remembered me for at the conference this
year like e-commerce stuff oh last year
this year
this year when they when they're like oh
i remember you talked about x
probably
investing the michael jordan house thing
that we talked about on the podcast wait
really
the idea of buying mj's house
so two things happened that went kind of
semi-viral in the sports and sports
media and sports agent world um people
shared that clip like remember the
twitter clip has like hundred thousand
plus views uh yeah people share that
with like people i think like the tick
tock thing was like millions
maybe you got to share with a lot of
people they were like oh i remember you
were gonna buy michael jordan's house
what happened with that and they were
like it's like dude you remember that
from over a year ago and like i'm doing
a bunch of other things way more
seriously that was just one
brainstorm with sam about this idea like
that's crazy so that was the first thing
uh people were remembering me for that
then then we um
while we were there ben took a call to
potentially invest in this company
and uh and i'm like cool what's this
guy's background and he the guy's done
many things ben goes you remember the
taco bell
mexican pizza dish i was like uh kind of
i guess like yeah i know it exists he
goes they took it away off the menu and
people like like were outraged on social
media and this guy got like a million
people to sign the petition to bring it
back and they brought it back
that's what he
well that's what ben remembered like
this guy's done a bunch of interesting
things and he had like three this guy
had three stories like that and once you
have like three stories like that
it's like all right i need to know this
guy and i feel like you do that really
well too where you have these little
things
where it's like ah the hot dog stand
like calls you know sam's wiener's his
biggest baby's arm
or it's like you know the pawns pawn
stars guy the pawn shop thing or like i
feel you have these things that are like
that these little nuggets are stories
that are like
they're memorable but not for the thing
you actually spent years of your life
building
yeah but dude the problem is is that i'm
like trading on old stories i need to do
some cooler [__] now
i'm like
you know we gotta like do some stuff i
gotta do something well i i think that's
the thing is like do more memorable [__]
because these punch above their weight
you know they don't take that long
they're not that hard to do but i was
gonna do like a
the other day i thought maybe i'll like
spend three weeks riding around on a
motorcycle and i was like that's lame i
already did that i gotta i gotta think
of some i gotta do something cool you
know right i think uh maybe i'll have
kids next year i gotta do something i
gotta go out with a bang
i don't think you understand what i'm
talking about
let's do something cool man we gotta do
something cool
let's do cool [__] yeah i think there's
a bunch of things that would be cool to
do but they don't make any sense and
what i'm learning is that those things
do make sense just on a different time
scale and uh you gotta like in a
different weird way and having the
having that little collateral of like
cool [__] that you could talk about is
worth it i thought about walking across
the country
and i was like that would be that'd be
pretty sick and then i kind of like
thought about like playing it out and
i'm like
huh
it's pretty far
it might take like six months
like i don't know like
you just listen to audio books all day
you know what i mean i gotta think of
some something like
kind of it's gotta be or authentic right
like extreme for extreme sake doesn't
work because again you don't know if
these are going to pay off or when
they're going to pay off so you got to
do it with the the act of doing it or
talking about it or like
that has to be itself enough
for you i was like maybe i'll just like
use twitter and like see if i can
hitchhike from like new york to
california
i don't know i gotta figure out
something
i'm gonna figure something out but this
stupid podcast i gotta be here all twice
a week to record it holds me back i
thought about walking across the country
but i gotta like gotta
carry around this lame-ass mic for the
stupid podcast
but i gotta figure something out
that's hilarious uh yeah let's do
another topic um
you remember how he tweeted out that
thing about hassan how do you spell out
pronounces i'll say minhaj
a comedian
yeah i tweeted out this thing that
basically i like saw him walk by me and
i went and grabbed him and goes what's
up man and it wasn't him and it was
really embarrassing
uh you know i've never like really
talked with him did you give him my
number
yeah oh
he texted me he was like this is funny
uh he's like give me sam's number uh and
i'll text him and then i send him your
number so i'm getting dinner with him um
and uh it's gonna be the first time i
didn't get to meet him when you do that
podcast but i thought that was also a
cool example of just like these cool
things just happen when you when you
take a lot of chances would you say that
maybe
your victory was in your vulnerability
here
by sharing this embarrassing story by
sharing this embarrassing story where i
look like a racist yeah
yeah all right your victory was in your
vulnerability baby and it was you hooked
it up so i appreciate that yeah it was
uh
i'm gonna i'm gonna go hang out with him
you guys are like homies right
uh yeah i really like him we uh you
better be funny dude
i'm not it's okay isn't that like you
got to go one way or the other if you're
going to hang out with a comedian you've
either got to be like
funny or just be like blatantly unfunny
is he funny when you're like just
hanging out with him
yeah he's a funny dude [__]
i'm not prepared at all i gotta go read
a book this is why i need that cool book
[__] try to be hot instead
no i can't do that either
you're closer to hot than funny
that's still a far i'm average at bo i'm
i'm average at best
like it's
all right try to be rich instead
dude i'm still a six out of ten on that
too
i'm just like a six panic of meeting the
panic of meeting uh famous people is so
funny to me uh
like i just think it's like a hilarious
thing that happens with people people
people meet famous people their instinct
is like
to just like throw
all good common sense out the window and
start behaving like an idiot dude it
just sucks being a seven at everything
you know what i mean i'm just a seven at
everything so
almost the bridesmaid
always the seven a jack of all trades a
master of nine i'm just as [__] seven
i need to like
it just doesn't work out um yeah but
you're you're a hard seven though you
know yeah i'm a hard seven all right
that's the pot we'll talk to y'all later
[Music]
you